tous les mardis à magny les hameaux et
jusque mi juin
les jeunes filles sont invités à
s'essayer au foot objectif recruter des
joueuses pour étoffer voir créer de
nouvelles équipes féminines le mani
football club et ses 400 licenciés s'est
lancé dans le football féminin cette
année 24 joueuses sont inscrits et ont
leurs créneaux d'entraînements dédié je
pensais pas que c'était bien parce qu'il
ya avec les garçons qui jouent et et qui
est des fibres et de nouveau c'est mon
frère y regarder tout le match à la télé
et du coup ça m'a donné envie de plus
m'intéresser aux routes pour les motiver
le club va les amener au parc des
princes assister au match d'ouverture de
la coupe du monde féminine
le 7 juin prochain dans le district des
yvelines les féminines représente 6,2
pour cent des licenciés alors qu'elles
n'étaient que 3 2% lors de la saison
2013 2014
un effectif en croissance qui correspond
à la volonté de féminisation du football
du président et de son équipe
l'idée qu'il que certains présidents ont
maintenant c'est de se dire va il faut
peut-être que j'ai une équipe de
football garçons de - pour pouvoir
laisser de la place à la création d'une
équipe de filles ça il ya dix ans
c'était impensable en tout cas ce
n'était pas le cas
et maintenant l'idée est en train de
faire son chemin c'est que c'est pas
parce que les garçons jouent au foot
depuis toujours qu'il faut pas aussi
laisser un petit peu de place aux
joueurs seuls 37 clubs sur 153 dans les
yvelines propose des sections féminines
pour les encourager le district les aide
en leur attribuant du matériel mais plus
que des joueuses dans les yvelines
on souhaite également plus de formatrice
il se trouve que malheureusement nous
n'avons pas assez de d'éducatrice nous
avons beaucoup d'éducateurs qui se
former mais pas assez d'éducatrice une
formation d'éducatrice et gratuit c'est
gratuit c est payant pour les messieurs
pour les hommes c'est gratuit pour les
femmes dans le district des yvelines
parce que les depuis toujours parce que
c'est une façon d'inciter
les filles à se former autre cheval de
bataille
l'encadrement sur les 153 club yvelinois
14 sont présidées par des femmes le
district organise des journées femmes
franchissait la barre hier pour
encourager les mamans un s'investir dans
les clubs de leurs enfants pour leur dit
tenir pour les prochains il faut tout
organiser pour que ce soit bien fait
parmi les quatorze présidents de clubs
dans les yvelines
mireille la faune et celle qui dirige
plus gros et l'encours et ses 800
licenciés après avoir inscrit ses deux
fils au club la mer s'investit pour
prendre de plus en plus de
responsabilités jusqu'à se retrouver à
la tête en juin dernier
au début c'est un challenge on se dit
est ce qu'on va y arriver est ce qu'on
va être reconnue parce que les femmes
dans le foot c'est pas encore
démocratisée mais c'est passionnant et
passionné on est très enrichissant et on
travaille avec des personnes dévouées
qui sont passionnés par le monde du
football et des parents un trimestre de
plus en plus la main à la pâte
la première section féminine d'elancourt
a été créé il y a dix ans aujourd'hui
elles sont 62 licenciés le club compte
également des formatrices une arbitre
une quasi parité au sein de son conseil
d'administration
il est le prochain à recevoir le label
du foot féminin des mains ou président
du district